how do you make something from nothing
almost two years after launching the
original nothing year one wireless
earbuds the Chinese company has
developed a follow-up the nothing year
twos from the way you work with the es6
functions to the new look and the new
settings you can customize nothing wants
to show that they have designed this
from the ground up but the question
remains if nothing has actually done
something with these or if they're all
hype and no hard it's actually reference
to a song well we're going to find out
when we compare these to its predecessor
and the Jabba Elite Force One of the
latest wireless earbuds available what
you get in the Box are the main butts
inside the case a pair of ear tips and a
type c cable everything you see here is
priced at 199 Singapore dollars we'll
quickly run through the differences
between the ear ones and the ear twos
starting with the keys for the ear twos
it is slightly smaller than the ear one
case and the bottom sticks out now for
more style points compared to the ear
once case which is pretty much just
smooth onto the butts they seemingly
look the same except that the ear2s have
these metallic contacts for it to
register your inputs by squeezing them I
cannot recall an earpiece that I've used
that uses squeezing instead of tapping
to activate the pieces functions but
this and say the physical buttons on the
job I lead for us we review that so you
can check it out like down here like
right here are great ways of avoiding
unwanted interruptions and missteps so
that's a welcome change just remember to
clean them regularly please so that no
Grime accumulates on a metallic contacts
or just anywhere on your earbuds because
that's gross like the EO ones the ear
twos are very comfortable when you put
them in your ears I can get a decent
seal of the ear tips that come with them
and I'd say their design is still quite
iconic ever since their predecessor
sworn build which reminds me we do have
the ear sticks down here however in the
case of the ear sticks
I hope nothing doesn't base any of their
future designs off of these even if they
are part of the affordable lineup
because having a design at such a size
isn't a good fit for everyone myself
included Marshall had a similar
designing ethos in the form of a shell
with the original minor earphones back
in 2011 and I'd say they became very
uncomfortable very quickly thankfully
things change with the mode and now the
motive ancs which I use as my daily
driver sound wise the ear tools have
drastically improved on the EO ones with
more clarity and oomph in the bass and
better well-rounded Mitten highs they do
do well with most genres but can
sometimes come off somewhat flat but I
think if you tweak The Equalizer to your
liking it would mitigate most of the
issues and yes they finally have
customizable EQ and it's something I'm
constantly asking every video when an
audio product doesn't have that option I
know some of you out there have your
opinions on equalizers but I do like
having that option
a lot there's also high-res audio with
these on certain Android devices and if
you're wondering if they sound different
on an Android and iOS device honestly
it's very marginal and you won't notice
a difference and see why the ear2s have
improved drastically from the ear ones
with canceling out the harm of a train
running on its tracks on the ground to
say a bus engine however high
frequencies still break through such as
train Chimes and voices they also have
adaptive ENC now and will have to run a
test in order to measure that the high
mode for ANC does well enough already so
if you want something more tailored to
you that option is available with
adaptive VNC also when you transition
from any mode to transparency mode the
earphones kind of breathe in your ear
for some reason I'm not sure if I can
capture that on the microphone but it
kind of sounds like
lastly the nothing X app is very
different from the last time I used it
with another year once it's much cleaner
smoother and of course has the custom EQ
and the ENT hub for the ear twos here
here at culture we've tested playing
to remain one of our favorites whether
it's for work or play they feel great to
lean back against with the ergonomic
features offering support for the whole
body from the head
and back to the arms and even something
for your butt this makes a format
function helps the Titan Evo 2020 to
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co now with all of that out of
the way let's talk about how these stand
against another pair of earbuds in its
class the Jabra Elite Force they both
released around the same time and the
nothing year twos cost 39 Singapore
dollars more than the Jabra Elite Falls
which are going for 160 Singapore
dollars and after using the both of them
it really just comes down to style and
function where the nothing year 2 is
offer stylish earbuds with decent audio
and ENC the Jabra v4s do slightly better
for cheaper but of course are more
stealthy and like the charm of the ear
tools the ANC works better on the jabras
yes but in some ways I prefer the sound
quality only nothing tools which have
more clarity and of course the comfort
that comes with them after using both
earbuds for several weeks on my commute
to and from work I'd still choose the
ear tools over the jabras because of how
comfortable they are because I get I
even have them on also I have to say
that the transparency mode on the ear
twos have improved a butt load they're
much better than the Java Elite Force in
that regard as well because they make
ambient sounds and having compositions
sound more natural also the Elite Force
lacks sensors that the ea2s have when
you remove a side to hot playback so if
you're picky about that just keep it in
mind it's a very close fight but if you
want Aesthetics with decent functions
the nothing here tools are right up your
alley however if you want a cheaper
option that does well functionally and
audibly the Jabra Elite Force are there
for you they both are ahead of the game
for earbuds in their price range and
some that are priced higher but that's
food for thought would you pick the
nothing you had to use over other
earbuds let me know in the comments
below because it is interesting what
nothing is doing with this pair of
earbuds the nothing ear tools have
surpassed the EO ones by a long shot
though nothing has managed to do
themselves with this offering I still
feel they have a long way to go to
properly solidify their place in the
audio space wow that rhyme companies
like Jabra are obviously years ahead of
nothing in terms of audio engineering
but it is exciting to see nothing do
great work so quickly in the spend of
less than two years with these so I
can't wait to see or rather hear how the
nothing year three sound like but are
they were the price at 199 Singapore
dollars I'll let you decide that in the
comments below if you have any questions
about these leave them there as well and
I'll do my best to get to them make sure
to follow us on all of our socials right
here so that you know you can keep up
with the latest news that we put out and
if you like this video make sure to like
And subscribe to us that goes a long way
and if you like this video check this
out
foreign
[Music]
thank you